[Music]
from chat GPT to do it might seem like
the pace of progress in artificial
intelligence is Unstoppable but the
artificial neural networks that underpin
these programs are coming up against
some major limitations for one they have
a hard time reasoning human brains are
able to Reason by analogy when we see
something new we don't have to grow new
neurons we can generalize new Concepts
from existing knowledge but artificial
neural networks struggle to Reason by
analogy in this way when confronting new
information they often require more
artificial nodes to scale up their
statistical abilities which enables them
to learn new Concepts this approach is
called statistical AI statistical AI is
at the heart of deep neural networks but
there is another competing approach
known as symbolic AI which uses logic
based programming and makes use of
symbols to to represent Concepts and
rules so by the very nature they are
incompatible and the Big Challenge is
that how we can combine them together to
get the best of for SPS an emerging
approach called hyperdimensional
Computing aims to do just that it Taps
into the power of statistical AI while
also trying to emulate symbolic
Computing it does this by using vectors
ordered lists of numbers that can also
represent arrows in space depending on
where they're pointing these vectors can
represent information in a highly comp
Lex multi-dimensional way they can
embody nuances and traits or concepts
just by small changes to their
orientation these vectors can combined
to represent new Concepts then be pulled
apart again to discern how they were
formed and crucially these
hyperdimensional vectors can incode
information without having to add more
nodes to the network the moments that we
bring hyperdimensional Computing or
vector symbolic architectures and Mar it
with the statistical methods such as
deep neural network we can have a
certain advantages in March 23 computer
scientists at IBM research in Zurich
made a dramatic Breakthrough by
combining statistical and symbolic
methods to solve the Raven's Progressive
Matrix a puzzle that asks an AI to
predict an image to fill the final
square of a 3X3 grid this is a classical
problems the first aspects is the
perception part where we look at
different visual objects and then we
have to recognize certain aspects of the
objects for example what is the shape of
the object what is the color what is the
size all these kind of the property and
the second aspect is to perform some
abstract reasoning on top of these kind
of attributes of the objects to be able
to solve a puzzle so for the first time
we combine hyper dimensional Computing
or vector symbolic architectures
Machinery with deep neural networks to
be able to solve abstract reasoning
problems at a scale essentially we can
build inside the neural network a
Machinery that is able to emulate any
symbolic Computing task that is hard for
the neural net NW work itself to do the
researchers also broke new ground by
solving the problem in record speed we
were able to significantly accelerate
the inference times of some of abstract
reasoning task you know by 250 times
having a method that is able to search
in this kind of the space rapidly it's
quite crucial to to be able to make them
quite practical for for uh larger scale
and real work problems although more
work is needed researchers like hoped
that hyperdimensional Computing could be
faster more transparent and more energy
efficient than current AI platforms we
can substantially reduce the energy
consumptions we are talking about you
know 10 times to 100 times lower energy
consumptions which can directly transfer
to lowering the carbon Footprints once
we are performing the inference of these
kind of the models solving Raven
Progressive matrices was just a
prototype it was so far amazing but the
fun is just beginning that's the
beauty
[Music]
in the 1990s mathematician Peter Shaw
developed an algorithm that threatened
to break the internet he was trying to
understand the power of quantum
computers and realized that they would
be able to rapidly break large numbers
into their prime factors that would
undermine one of the central methods of
modern cryptography that has safeguarded
online privacy for decades so when I
discovered the algorithm I just called
it the factoring algorithm the quantum
factoring algorithm and I published it
and soon people started calling it
shor's algorithm at the heart of shor's
algorithm is the act of repeatedly
multiplying one number with itself until
the output of a certain function starts
repeating the required number of
multiplications called the functions
period can be used to find the prime
factors of any large number for the last
30 years this has been the fastest known
algorithm for factoring integers then in
August 2023 mathema I odad regev
published a groundbreaking new paper
sh's algorithm is is great in the sense
that it allows quantum computers to
factorize integers and do it quickly I
was asking myself if it can be made even
faster regev suspected that he could
speed up Shore's algorithm by
transforming the periodic function from
one dimension to multiple Dimensions
that meant including more numbers
multiplying each with itself many times
over to find the period of repetition in
the outputs in doing so regev
established an improved method to factor
integers faster and more efficiently
Char algorithm is about finding how long
you have to walk on the line to get back
to where you started in the new
algorithm we no longer walk on the line
we walk on a plane or even
threedimensional space or more the idea
is that you can walk both you know right
left but also top down on the plane so
it could be for instance that if you
walk four steps to the right and five
step up you'll be back to where you
started from Odin's um Improvement my
album came out of the blue there wer
there wasn't any you know work leading
up to it he just had a really good idea
and he sat down and figured it out and
um published a paper like Shore's
algorithm regev's new algorithm remains
theoretical in nature speaking to a
potential future when Quantum Computing
becomes more practical I would be happy
if if it turns out that this new
algorithm is more practical it has some
of the components that could make it
more practical but it's not clear yet if
it's really there my algor is what 30
years old now and ODed found an
improvement on it that nobody had
thought of before I wouldn't be
surprised if people came up with more
Innovative Quantum algorithms and um
it's quite possible that someone will
improve factoring algorithm even further
we already knew how to factor as
integers using Sha's algorithm so this
new algorithm is kind of just an you
know speed up what I would really like
to know if is if quantum computers can
do things that we just didn't know how
to
[Music]
do which movie do these emojis represent
when researchers asked three different
large language models they got very
different answers the simplest AI
struggled to come up with a coherent
answer a somewhat more complex model
spit out something reasonable but still
wrong but the most complex system nailed
it in just one try this impressive
result can be explained by a range of
exciting new abilities AI researchers
are calling emergent behaviors something
that is not present in a small language
model that becomes present in a larger
model it can be said to have emerged we
don't think that it'll be there and then
we scale it up and all of a sudden this
phenomenon is already there and so it's
not necessarily A predictable
phenomenon emergence happens when a
system behaves in ways its individual
units don't on their own this phenomenon
can be seen across nature such as when
lifeless atoms give rise to living cells
water molecules create waves and
starlings swarm and swoop is one
researchers are seeing that if enough
digital nodes combine in large language
models surprising new behaviors can
emerge these behaviors are distinct
departure from older neural networks
which process language word by
painstaking word in 2017 a key piece of
code known as a Transformer was
introduced to llms enabling neural
networks to analyze words in parallel
now llms can process strings of text in
an instant the models we were training
before seemed to struggle with a lot of
kind of more abstract tasks more
generalization and what we've seen since
Transformers is that if we train much
larger models they're better at those
tasks the magic of Transformers is that
they're extremely good at solving
sequence prediction problems so given a
bunch of items in a sequence predict the
next thing and this is particularly good
for building generative models of for
example language and also images this
year researchers have reported a range
of emergent behaviors that enable llms
to solve problems they've never seen
before this is known as zero shot or F
shot learning and it's long been a goal
in artificial intelligence but as
exciting as the results are researchers
still have questions about what exactly
is underpinning these emergent abilities
people are trying to figure out like at
what point is that there a Tipping Point
one Theory suggests that emergence
happens when large language models break
down complex tasks into smaller steps
this process is called Chain of Thought
reasoning but the true source of the
Tipping Point into emergence remains a
mystery the models get better as they
get bigger and people are releasing
bigger models at a pretty rapid clip
meanwhile the science of understanding
what's happening under the hood
progresses more slowly than that so one
of the challenges with the mergence is
that it's unpredictable because on the
one hand you know bigger models
typically mean better models but on the
other hand bigger models also can uh
demonstrate novel behaviors that the
developers didn't anticipate a priori
these can be beneficial behaviors but
they can also be harmful behav behaviors
so the ways in which they will be used
or are used are still unfolding and
therefore it's equally important to
measure the possible types of harms that
might be espoused in these models and
how they emerge or do not emerge with
scale and so things feel quite
unpredictable right now um but I don't
think they will always be
[Music]
unpredictable